salve youtubers benvenuti ad una
nuova recensione prima di
iniziare la come al solito
vorrei consigliare un canale e
canale 10
the signor marco carola
blocchiamo il signor marco
monsignor a. che fa
percorsi fra virgolette per
quanto
persol youtube si possono fare
corsi di regia appunto di regia
re
dubay spiega diciamo a grandi
linee le cose principali per
seguire le linee
il principale da seguire
per fare regia lo fa con uno
stile molto personale e
soprattutto molto molto
simpatico
quindi io vi metto il link e
nelle informazioni archivio
iscrivetevi perchè ne vale la
pena
anche tu anche se volete
abbordare mio speciale di
halloween e nel secondo canale
metto lo metto come video
risposta a questo qui quindi se
volete cliccate arrivato
direttamente lì
detto questo
iniziamo la nuova recensione
e devo dire che questo film mi
ha fatto veramente incazzare è
un film
the last time
il film in questione
monster mangio tutta l'arte del
ben più famoso cover film mi
assumo a gradini della trama
un mostro invade tokyo
due ragazze guarda caso
americane hanno firmato il tutto
dici che sono molto difficile
riuscire a recensirlo perchè
paolo schifo tremendo
ma fa schifo piccole dosi che
cavolo vuol dire fa schifo a
piccole dosi
numero 5
bastardi
sapete cosa cavolo hanno
combinato qui giri della
sailboat su internet hanno detto
che sarebbe uscito questo film
rover freelander nelle sale
americane
allora cosa valuta la brillante
idea di fare
noi leggiamo tutte le
informazioni possibili su questo
film e prima che esca
e ci facciamo february
i ludi sentiamo 3 giorni prima
di cover feed così tutti i
cannot rupert ed ha copiato
monster ma brutti psicopatici ma
ti pare ma come fa come avete
potuto qui
sai che sarebbe potuto
funzionare una porcata del
genere ma non ha funzionato per
due motivi principali
il film fa schifo everyday the
fatto malissimo 2 dolores
nessuna vostro film non sei
infatti uno dei più sconosciuti
della salma come ho detto prima
una bastardata ma uscita
malissimo
numero quattro
1 danno monica
io odio mettere questi punti
nelle recensioni perchè sono
troppo poco interessanti
mail libero
mi spiegate come fa un film con
gusto che distrugge tutto per
caso essere noioso non ho non
come fai a essere noioso mi
correggo
come il phantom a renderlo
noioso hermoso khz
farai un posto che attacca
nascita scommetto che se lo fai
d
4 morlupo 4 mori 2-1 per niente
e allora com'è possibile che
questo scempio sia anche noioso
better che le per la maggior
parte del tempo si vedono queste
due ragazze che parlano parlano
parlano parlano parlano parlano
canguro parlano parlano piangono
parlano chiaro moka calcolo
parcella dettagliata
maltempo si chiama poster dove
porca miseria esto mostrerà
tutti siamo utili per chi si è
già rotto le palle 20 volte che
si fa toccare con dire che si è
rotto le palle due volte al
minuto
numero 3
la trama
c'ho messo un bel punto
interrogativo dopo trama
perchè non sono riuscito a
capirla
io l' non voglio un metro
paragone con coverfix perché
non mi sembra giusto
in copertina puntata del
figliuol di farmacia cioè
spiego meglio
un motivo per cui nonostante ci
sia un mostro che attacca la
città
i protagonisti continuo a
filmare soprattutto al non
scappare dalla città improve
file per quanto stupido forse
c'era
loro vanno a cercare la ragazza
di uno dei protagonisti la
prendo e poi scappano culi non
sono riuscito ad afferrarla la
trama come ho detto prima ci
sono loro che camminano per il
tuo occhio nonostante non lo
sanno circa metà film
scoprono che sei un mostro che
distrugge tutto
perché cacchio non se ne vanno
che a milano a casa e si ritrova
dentro te concato della città
dove guarda caso spesso
il mostro attacca ma senza un
filo logico anche se ad un certo
punto non ho cercato
all'ambasciata americana
penultimo che mi è sfuggito ci
tecnicamente non lo vogliono
aggiungere l'ambasciata
americana per poi scappare da
tokyo
ora parte l' elenco delle cose
che le protagoniste avrebbero
potuto fare per scappare
finalmente invece di andare all
ambasciata americana mappa
città distrutta ruba una
macchina sign in giappone è il
più di biciclette rubo la
bicicletta scappo correndo piedi
da qualsiasi altra parte che non
si è certo tipo che dove c'è
gusto che sta attaccando tutto
primi incontri e tagliati le
vene
tutto questo per dire che le
scenette subito perchè le
persone correlate quali anche
col bastone
sto con i miei che sono
appoggiati una sopra l'altra in
una maniera pietosa un
ringraziamento speciale agli
sceneggiatori di fine della sai
neanche riesco a dare sempre il
peggio di loro stessi
2 1 2
scenette quasi a caso ecco
quindi siamo già a parlare un
po' più della computer grafica
del mostro
come spiegartelo questo avete
presente quando avete un
vecchietto speciale preimpostate
già fatto e dovete cercare di
mischiarlo al film e' molto
difficile infatti non ce la fa
nessuno di solito
sibili mischiare un effetto
speciale film
giri tutti i tuoi file effetto
speciale sopra
il film
ma questa è la samuel umberto
esempio quando un posto sta
uscendo dal terreno ci sono le
crepe per terra oppure quando il
vostro
con i tentacoli perché dovrebbe
su una piovra gigante ma non si
fa
colite katakolon distrugge tutto
&amp fa volare le automobili
think love feel the present
succedevano queste cose
c'era il cameraman che stava
riprendendo una cosa
poi certo punto si girava e
nella stessa vi presento
rimettevano gli effetti speciali
veniva una cosa quasi realistica
non lo spegnere pc dopo
le riprese si vedono
cose a caso tipo soldati o le
due ragazzi dipende poi
stacco milano
sparco degli effetti speciali
staccoli roma ripresa di nuovo
sulle persone a caso questo
sempre sempre sempre
contatti questi effetti speciali
appaiano 4 5 volte in un film di
un'ora e mezza loro devono farsi
tristar culi effetto speciale
sta cu niru ripreso di quello
che si riprendano prima questo
metodo è una tecnica molto
precisa
usata solo da registi
all'avanguardia zincata anche
sui manuali di cinema a chiamata
grandissima puttanata
numero 1
monsieur
e con questa posizione cerchio
di racchiudere tutto il
putridume che ho lasciato il mio
alle spalle con le reply me 4
posizioni
io voglio vedere il vostro
voglio vederlo
voglio vederlo distruggere tutto
voglio vedere uccidere persone
voglio vedere lanciare concetti
aguzzo voglio vedere palo
crollare palazzi
non perchè sono sangue ma
perchè ex guardo un film con un
posto
teoricamente posso dire
fantastico coppa atac
altra domanda per voi
secondo voi se loro non riesco a
fare la crepa nel terreno la
macchina che viene lanciata in
contemporanea con le altre
yep scene che stanno girando
il cazzo di moto come la fanno
vedere
esatto non l'ho fatto vedere o
meglio al usato questo giochetto
delle disintegrare
il nastro la pellicola lalli
digitale quel che la telecamera
ogni volta che tempo da moto
marilyn che coincidenza fortuita
così lo spettatore non so mai
acquistato dal parlare
incessante delle due
protagoniste
ma non può neanche godersi un
po' di computer grafica
squallida perchè non te la
fanno vedere ma porca eva con lo
sto guardando non si vede una
cippa mi spiegate come cazzo
faccio a recensione film e se
non si vede nulla ma poi
skoda astrostar memory card non
so con quale telecamera abbiamo
girato
ma quante volte si può ordinare
mature in quanti modi si può
rovinare
perchè ogni volta che si mi
rilasso rovinato i rovinato in
14 mia moglie si
una volta si vede la pellicola
che va sui giuri quindi pensi
che una pellicola
una volta si vede di pixel che
scuotono 15 digitale mai
visitato con il nastro housing
lido di merda ma poi vogliamo
parlare del finale preferirei di
no ma comunque parliamo di
finale in una scena
completamente a caso uguale a
tutte le altre
una delle protagoniste delle
completamente esibire
schiacciato da un pentacolo
gigante e li capisci aw che
siamo vicini alla fine del film
e ringraziando il cielo ma cosa
succede sacco nero ovviamente
ripresa
cortili camera totalmente
disintegrata
per amica
chi è sopravvissuta con un po
di sangue faccio una ferita al
fianco
non sono sicuro che
tentacoli di 40mila tonnellate
chi cade addosso
se il feto soltanto a fianco un
po di sangue in testa
ma come se non bastasse
confsal succedendo la telecamera
cosa succede
secondo me quello finale ligure
un effetto speciale
e' proprio la telecamera che
dopo essersi rotta i coglioni di
questo film e serie auto
distrutta vi giuro purtroppo
questo film ho guardato da solo
altrimenti ci saremmo annoiati
in due
perchè non è divertente da
guardare con gli amici
non è divertente da guardare da
solo non è abbastanza squallido
2 days e divertente
trucchi per
orribile che non dovrebbe mai
essere visto da nessuno io mi
segnala un sito a guardare
questo film perché io questo
genere di film
lo adoro i film in prima persona
dave kelbrick 2 cooper fibre
ebay buys fronte per quanto
fosse una cagata ep cannibal
holocaust baci a tutti quelli
giapponesi per decesso
tantissimi sconosciuti a me
piacciono quindi
questa cosa l'ho presa molto
cuore
unlock oddio la sai qualcosa di
più di quanto lo desideri ma
esi gia prima esterna col mio
odio verso la file met urlando
alla telecamera ora come diavolo
fanno
arrabbiare ancora di più con
loro
esatto